So, I've got some good news and
I've got some bad news.
What do you want to hear first?
Stark as always.
All right, well,
I'll tell you the good news first.
So, the beta testers love the ability
to share with their friends.
You can see that here
Paulter's rating about it.
Well, as much as Paulter raves.
Bad news is that we've
got a couple of one and
two star reviews complaining that
they're having trouble finding
their friends in
the massive user accounts.
Katie here says that she
loves the sharing feature.
But with over 400 users, she can't
find any of her actual friends.
I'm thinking maybe the thing to work on
next to deal with some of these issues
is some sort of auto complete
searching functionality.
And, I'm guessing we could use
of Firebase's query features
to implement this functionality.
I'm going to think about how you
might implement it a little bit more.
But, while you're waiting,
why don't you jump on a call with JP
to learn a little bit more about
range queries in Firebase.